welcome to the Yale School of Forestry
and environmental studies tonight on
this chilly evening thanks for coming
out and to tonight's panel discussion
conflict and natural resources
integrated civilian military
perspectives and approaches my name is
Dave de Fusco I'm the communications
director Fe NS and am editor of
environment yell magazine and the
discussion tonight was inspired in part
by a future article by Richard conniff
that will appear in the Fall issue of
environment yell that is due out in two
weeks Richard you want to raise your
hand and let everyone by the way Richard
just published a book called the species
seekers heroes fools in the mad pursuit
of life on earth so if you're looking
for a good book for Christmas gift ask
Richard afterward the environment Yale
article is called forestry on the front
lines and in it he describes the efforts
of the three distinguished gentleman
sitting here on my right in establishing
a joint civilian military team in
eastern Afghanistan to address how
natural resources smuggling insurgency
criminality and government corruption
fuel conflicts around the world that
project is called the natural resources
counterinsurgency sell at task force
Pistone and it is a successor to the
Army's task force mountain warrior of
which US Army Colonel Randy George was
commander Colonel George served to
Operation Iraqi Freedom tours as a
battalion commander was an adviser to
the multinational corps commander and is
now a military fellow at the Council on
Foreign Relations Dante Paradiso as a
member of the State Department guided
the team's effort while relying upon his
considerable knowledge of these issues
from his service in Liberia Dante is a
yale college graduate in a career
foreign service officer most recently
serving as deputy political economic
counselor at the u.s. embassy and addis
ababa Harry Bader is an F ENS doctoral
candidate who works for the US Agency
for International Development he holds a
law degree from Harvard and is a tender
tenured professor at the University of
Alaska Fairbanks school of Natural
Resources in the midnight 1980s he went
to elf solve
door during its civil war on a US aid
project looking at land reform as a
means of reducing support for the
guerrilla movement and in early 1990s he
worked in Bosnia for the United Nations
using spectral imaging and other
techniques to locate mass graves beneath
the forest canopy I'll start the
conversation off by asking Harry a
simple question how and why did you get
involved in this effort well I can start
this off very easily bypassing the
question off to Dante Paradiso because
iris I was sent to eastern Afghanistan
at the request of mr. Paradiso and
Colonel George because they are the ones
who saw a particular need that could be
fit that could be satisfied by USAID a
special program that kind of combines
development with counter insurgency and
so with that I will pass it off to Dante
to to discuss how it was that this
request came about well thanks Harry
just one quick thing at you know it's
great to be here yo forestry school
because actually you got my start in a
lot of international work because I knew
somebody who was at the Yale forestry
school guy named Peter Lewis who went
and did the backcountry trail program
with the California Conservation Corps
for many years he recently passed away
but he was certainly a legend around
these parts and you know it's it's a
real honor to be here speaking to this
crowd and thank you all for coming out
on a Monday evening we got Harry
involved in part because we had heard
that there were some issues with timber
in the area that we were engaged and our
Brigade covered four provinces in
eastern Afghanistan and Colonel George
will talk a little bit more about the
area of responsibility but I'm going to
start on a comparative note because when
you really look at conflict and natural
resources is really kind of falls into
three baskets
you know the first is what you hear is
you know indigenous folks sort of in
conflict with maybe a central government
or government that is looking to take
over resources for one reason or another
and that can be a driver of conflict the
second area is really competing groups
that are fighting for control of a
resource and then the third area which
is the part that has had the most
international attention most
international response in recent years
is conflict that is monetizing a natural
resource to perpetuate a conflict and
the case that I was most familiar with
because I'd served there was Liberia
where the Charles Taylor regime was
basically selling out the natural
resources to local to international
consortiums that were coming in cutting
down the timber and and then selling it
on the international market and what
Taylor was doing was taking the proceeds
of that fund to fuel regional conflict
it was also internal conflict because he
was facing you know a multi-pronged
insurgency but at the same time he was
also using it to destabilize neighboring
countries and Charles Taylor is
currently on trial in The Hague for that
but we had heard that there was you know
some sort of problem and the other way
to look at natural resources in conflict
is there's really two prisms that we
approached the problem the first prism
is environmental you know a lot of folks
get involved in natural resources
because they're basically worried about
you know land degradation the economic
damage to local communities and things
like that and they basically address
natural resources through that prism and
then there's the conflict prism which is
okay the resources are being degraded
but the main problem is is that they are
contributing to instability and so you
cannot address the other problem they're
obviously interrelated and we found that
in Afghanistan
the main point though is that you have
to understand the local context so that
you can apply the remedies so remedies
that we applied in Liberia were
international sanctions on the regime
and you could actually get a number of
people in the international community to
agree to a ban on the export of Liberian
timber and it was driven for two reasons
you know the first reason was concerned
of the degradation of the forests there
and so I think that led to a lot of the
international pressure that eventually
led to a ban and the second way you
could look at it or the way it was
approached was to you know really go
after the actors in the conflict and try
to broker a peace on the ground so that
you could at some point get beyond this
as a fuel for conflict timber is
actually something that you can apply
this remedy to because it's large it's
easy to track and when you move it into
other countries it's very easy to know
sort of where it's coming from and where
the ships are coming from it's a lot
harder with smaller resources like
diamonds and I think everybody's heard
about you know conflict diamonds or
blood diamonds in Afghanistan when we
arrived what we found is is that the
government had basically put a ban on
the movement and sale of timber in local
regions and you know i think it was
environmentally driven because there is
a in certain areas with certain types of
timber and Harry will get into a lot
more details on that there is an
environmental degradation problem that's
not insignificant and that has problems
for you know and has consequences for
the long-term sustainability of timber
as a as an economic benefit to
communities so the solution that was
sort of being applied was to ensure that
nothing would really happen until a good
legal regime was in place on the right
tax structure
in place and then the government had the
right mechanisms by which to control and
manage the resource properly so that was
understandable as to why they were doing
it but what we found is is that that set
local communities in opposition to the
government because the local communities
have been managing this resource off and
on in times of conflict for many many
years and so when we look at the
solutions that we applied you realize
you it's not very easy to you know say
okay well we'll solve the conflict
timber problem in Afghanistan with an
international solution like ban on
timber or a local solution like banning
the movement of timber which again can
do certain things to prove i earn mental
degradation but what it struggles to do
is figure out how to help those
communities one survive economically and
to not move in opposition to the
government because what happened was it
led to a proliferation smuggling and
then what we found in certain cases is
that that smuggling was tied into the
insurgency or was directly funding the
insurgency interestingly that was not
true in all cases which meant that there
was an opportunity for mediation between
the local community and the government
by trying to bring them together to
commonly look at the problem and find
out it the best way that they could
manage the resource together and that's
part and parcel of a little bit about
what we were doing there I'm going to
turn it over to the colonel to speak a
little bit about our area and then some
themes that we saw developed
particularly as we develop joint
civilian military strategy to address
the problem okay you leave me everybody
I'm certainly honored to be here
have a lot of great folks that have come
through here we've talked it a couple of
these others and certainly Afghanistan
or the war in Afghanistan is very
controversial wouldn't talk about one
specific piece of it which is timber and
I think that you'll find that it's kind
of instructive there's a lot of problems
and some of the things that we'll talk
about is jump into conclusions about how
you solve certain problems and
oftentimes make things worse and that's
kind of one of the things that that we
found with with timber but we can
certainly talk about other issues during
question-and-answer you can get an idea
of the terrain it's up in the up in the
northeastern Afghanistan and you can
also imagine what it takes that they
would actually be dragging this timber
around this afghan cedar up through
there you could go from about 5,000 feet
to fourteen or fifteen thousand feet
about five kilometers so on about 5,000
feet it just gives you an idea just how
rough that terrain is we had four
provinces in the Northeast it's in the
Pashtun belt up in the Northeast except
for nourished in which was strictly a
different tribe and that was probably
the most remote area but very heavily
timbered a lot of gems to some of the
stuff you may have seen in the news
about they have extensive amount of gems
a lot of that is up in that part of
northern Afghanistan about 3.5 million
people once again a lot of those were
down at nanga har you may have heard in
manga Haaretz where the Tora Bora
mountains so when that comes up and you
talked about where Osama bin Laden was
that was in the southern part bar area
escaped and the Pakistan it's about 375
kilometers or so of
Pakistan and that's all important with
the border with Pakistan just because
it's it's very porous border and a lot
of these tribes that are in kunar for
example are connected to the folks
across and a lot of the timber that
we'll talk about that was smuggled out
was going that's that's where this head
okay first and I'm going to quote
somebody because i'm reading the rule
interesting book i know that was written
by professor Scott here James Scott in
the 90s and his this book is seeing
seeing like a state and the premise is
basically that you a lot of times
especially Mason's Mason government's
third-world countries will impose
certain laws or rules from the center
without having any real idea of how
things are worked out on the ground I
think one of his first examples he used
as he goes through a forestry example
this was very much what we saw in
Afghanistan and like I said we'll talk
specifically about the timber but a lot
of this was also done they would be
implemented a forty percent tax on gems
and what that just guaranteed was that
they were going to get basically nothing
to the central government by having such
a such a high tax so it was it was a
common problem for us over there and
very little very little with those kind
of rules going down to the local level
and really seeing how things would work
and Harry we'll get to that i'm sure i'm
talking about how they were taking care
of the forest but it went with gems and
with marble and it also goes to
basically understand the local solutions
when you're standing up even security
forces that were over there so it i
think that this is important lesson for
us to to hold in to learn
just for counter insurgency operations
but also for any kind of stability
operations or also if our if our country
is going to go out and provide help to
other nations is understanding what some
of these centralized rules help what
they can interact in the kind of
backlash that they can have second is
this there's a lot you know you talk
about military problems or civilian
problems and I think one of the big
things that we try to tell everybody
about is these aren't clearly military
or civilian problems that are problems
and it gives you an idea of you just
haven't have to have an understanding of
what that problem is if you're going to
attack it we had 6500 military and I
think we had 41 civilians in our task
force from several different agencies
that were in there so a lot of maybe
resources that were from the Department
of Defense at but then a lot of very
specific expertise in the other
departments that we had to rely on to
understand the problem our approach was
basically we didn't talk about and we
did talk about the enemy as if that's a
facet and something you had to recognize
when you're fighting an insurgency or
any war but what we really tried to
focus on was what was the problem that
we had to understand the problem and the
key to this was specifically with timber
there wasn't a military solution of
going in someplace to a village with the
military operation trying to shove
something down that was really going to
help this problem get better it really
was understanding it was their
livelihood then that's how they had
survived for several hundred years they
were going to continue to do it despite
the rules that were put in place by the
central government and we had to under
what that was so we really tried to
focus all of our collection on really
mapping the human terrain that was out
there and understanding the laws and
everything that went with it so that
meant understanding who the power
brokers were in a certain area because a
lot of times those power brokers control
resources you had to understand who
those people were that was different if
that was somebody who was a warlord and
was causing instability than a family
that just had timber and needed to use
and was basically even it was against
the law very legitimate in their
business and moving into crust across
the border and then the other thing that
kind of goes along with that is the
interleague inter linkage of the
problems of that specific problem with
timber that we faced you'll find in
Afghanistan there's somebody there you
have families will have people in the
Afghan border police in the Afghan
National Police have been maybe somebody
that's involved in a criminal
organization or an insurgent group it
makes its very complex and the reason
that that's important is it because of
that law off of what what ended up
happening was you would have the afghan
national police or the border police
actually assisting with some of the
smuggling that was happening and what
that did was further degraded the really
how everybody viewed the government or
to what they were doing how legitimate
the governor
was by their involvement in those kind
of practices so it was kind of a
snowballing effect when when dealing
with the lumber and that went with
governor's districts of governors like I
said the tribal leaders and the and the
power brokers I'm gonna introduce Harry
Harry probably one of the most humble
professionals that I've ever met and
he's an example of I think when of civ
mill operations when you get the right
guy who's really brilliant works 20
hours a day that's probably a good
average for what Harry put in over there
just what kind of an effect that he can
have on the ground and really describing
that problem so we go about applying
right solution thank you one of the
things i'm colonel george and mr.
paradiso and i decide what we wanted to
do tonight is to open this up as a
discussion with questions and comments
and dialogue to the extent practicable
and so what I'll do just to give a quick
snapshot is I'll present just ten
PowerPoint slides and give an overview
of the area what the problems were and
what the solution is that Colonel George
and Dante brought to this to this and in
the setting up of the Natural Resources
counter-insurgency cell that's been
carried on my task force Bastogne so
I'll just quickly go through that and
then I think we can answer any questions
or entertain comments just very quickly
oh and also I am an involuntary Luddite
so I just have one quick question is
what button do I push to advance the the
answer okay is that right okay that's
that's like just shows you that I'm an
old-school kind of person the 1905 Yale
curriculum would have been just fine for
me so this gives you an idea you often
times you will see pictures of
Afghanistan that is a desolate barren
desert for much of the area where we're
operating in
that is not the case these are forests
above 9,000 feet from the most part
starting about 7,000 feet going up to
about 14,000 feet of spruce pine
evergreen oak cedar and fir the target
species that is harvested and smuggled
is the cedar cedar st adoro and again
this just gives you an idea of what the
forest type is but I also want to point
out the operation necessary to do this
particular transect that we did over the
forest and Kunar was a intensive
military operation that required a lot
of planning a lot of assets and so we
talked about joint civilian military
operations it goes down to every single
aspect of Colonel George and don t
paradiso had not shepherded this process
through something as expensive as this
that required multiple helicopters
assistance people ready to assist if we
had trouble just to get a forest transit
to find out what was out there but again
this gives you an idea of the type of
forest again it's a mixture of cedar and
some juniper actually see some juniper
there and pine and and and spruce so one
of the things that Dante alluded to was
that in the lower elevations were
evergreen oak forests called balute
which we did not focus on because these
forests which are susceptible to
significant ecological degradation from
clear-cutting or low value forests that
do not get smuggled and harvested and
funneled into the insurgency or criminal
actors or the communities but rather
these are the force of life that every
farmer has to have access to to lop for
fodder for their livestock disease are
evergreen Oaks to use to heat their
homes in winter and to cook their food
and for those of you are familiar
Central Asia their bread is cooked in an
open oven and so when USAID comes in and
plants eucalyptus in community forests
woodlots it doesn't work for purposes of
keep your bread and so this forest type
we didn't focus on but it is an
environmental problem it's a low value
forest from a commercial standpoint but
it's a necessary would source for life
to exist and its destruction without
management is destabilizing but what
we're concerned about was the upper
evergreen forests and I use this slide
which is unfortunate because this is a
very rare occurrence what they're doing
is they're practicing for the most part
group selection cuts an extraordinarily
good forest management practice which
you don't normally see in a conflict
forest environment I use this as an
example because two competing timber
barons fought over this Ridge and the
the loser then burned it before the
winner could could utilize it and so
it's one of these cases where this
massive scale of loss of timber is
extremely rare it's it's rare because
it's a waste of resources and money one
of the things that we did that mr.
paradiso focused a lot of resources for
us to focus on is how to map the nexus
among the insurgency criminal actors and
the Afghan government and the key to
that were these brands that are on every
single can't that is harvested cut and
exported and what we tried to do is find
out what did these what did these brands
mean we finally broke the code and were
able to then assess where the timber was
coming from to whom it was benefiting
and how much value and that that broke
open everything we could actually then
identify which values which valleys had
timber that was financing insurgency
which valleys had timber there was
financing criminal cartels and which
valleys were just enriching the local
community and that ladder is the
dominant theme when we'll get to that in
just a second and it will open up for
questions the other thing that we were
doing
is mentoring platoons on community
engagement in these areas and we've used
a couple of anecdotal examples in the
past where how to engage the community
in order to win an ally as opposed to
find a foe by how you interact with the
smugglers and we'll talk about this but
this particular where this wasn't
particular patrol but there was a
particular patrol where they were
bringing cedar out which is technically
a criminal activity but the second
lieutenant engaged the smugglers rather
trying to interdict them so as to avoid
a fight and then found out that this
shipment of cedar with not going to
Pakistan was not going to enrich a
criminal cartel is not going to enrich
insurgency was going to go into the
interior for the construction of a
mosque that the United States was
funding so had this young lieutenant use
violent interdiction to crack down on it
we would have had a foe and instead we
had a friend who was stunned and then
told the rest of the community that that
mosque was us-funded and that lieutenant
was later invited to a family wedding
that is counterinsurgency the way joints
of mill teams need to operate in order
to win the other thing that Dante
alluded to is that we had to profile who
the insurgents were recruiting for
mid-level leadership in these villages
who is susceptible to be recruited for
mid-level leadership in these villages
and who was resistant to being recruited
for mid-level and I keep saying good
level good level mid-level because we
can hire every single seventh born son
in the community in a cast for work
program ninety-five percent of the men
could be higher in that community by
USAID and have not one impact on that
community's loyalty to either the
insurgency to the Afghan government or
to nobody but if you target the the
respected we use the term of the shades
happen II I'm sure many of you have seen
the movie Shane Shane was not a sheriff
she was not the rancher who owned all
the land
she was a guy who wrote in the town and
everyone respected by his integrity and
his ability and his intellect and people
rallied around him and did the right
thing this program is trying to find the
shins in the community get them on board
to Natural Resources stewardship and a
way from being susceptible to being
drawn into the insurgency if we can find
an opportunity for men to bring respect
to the reputation while benefiting your
community in that community we can keep
them from trying to gain respect in the
community through the use of a gun and
we've been time and again informed by
village leaders our men have no
opportunity to a teen status other than
that buy a gun because most of your
additional mechanisms have been
destroyed by 30 years of war and with
that we close and open up for questions
and comments and again it's an
incredible forest type it looks a lot
like his professor and can't point it
out it looks like wenatchee you know it
looks like northern Idaho it really does
it's extraordinary sort we had we had
trees with a dbh of 5 feet 140 feet tall
and these are incredible trees and with
that I'll turn it over to Colonel George
and Dante Paradiso to control the
questions and make comments and ready to
run